Welcome back! In the previous section
we talked about higher-order functions.
Functions that take
functions as arguments or return functions
as results.
In particular we looked at two
higher-order functions over lists:
filter and map. And we
indicated that these two functions had a
very similar structure.
They were both defined inductively over
the structure
of the list. And since we are lazy
programmers
we want to capture that pattern into yet
another higher-order function, that we
can then use
to define filter and map, or in fact as
many functions over lists as possible.
That function that captures recursively
descending over the structure of a list
is called
foldr. There is also a function foldl.
What does this l and r mean?
Foldr means fold from the right. And just
like when we say that the
northern wind comes from the north, fold
right
is a fold that comes from the right.
So it comes from the right, it starts
with the empty list and then folds
from there on. Here
is the definition of foldr.
As I said foldr captures the essence
of recursing over a list.
What is recursing over a list? Well,
we have two cases.
One when the list is empty and
one when the list
is composed of a list with
a value in the front. So in case
we have an empty list, when we
apply this recursive function
we have to pick a value for the empty list.
Let's say that value is v. So f of the
empty list is v.
When we do f apply to x:xs
we recursively call f on xs.
That was the whole goal.
And now we have to take the result of this
recursive invocation
and combine it with the value on top. And
we use
the operator plus for that.
So f maps the empty list to
some value v and it maps the
non-empty list
to some function plus and applies that
function plus to the head of the list x
and to the recursive call of the
function to its tail.
In some sense you can see what this
function f does
is it traverses the list and replaces
the empty list with v
and that replaces every occurrence of cons
with plus.
It remains the structure. So another
way to say this is that
f is a homomorphism over list. It
respects the structure of the list.
And that is what we are after here.
Here are a couple of
examples of using
functions that are defined recursively
over lists, for example: sum takes
the empty list, returns 0
and when I sum the list x:xs, I
do x plus the sum of xs. The product
is very similar. Instead of 0 I have 1
and instead of plus we use star. And if
we want to
and all the values of a list, then we
replace the empty list by
True and the cons
by and. So here you see
very very similar structures and in
particular we can
instantiate v and plus very simply.
In the first case the empty list v
is replaced by 0.
And cons, that was the funny plus
is plus. In the second case here, we
replace the empty list by 1, so v
equals 1.
We replace cons by multiplication, so
the funny plus is times. And in the
last case
simple, we replace the empty list by True
so v is True, and we replace
cons by and, so funny plus
is and. Alright? So here we can define
sum, product, or and and
in terms of foldr simply as foldr of plus
and 0, product is foldr of times and 1
et cetera. Look what we have done.
We looked at these three functions and we
see that these are just
instances of this foldr function with
a particular v
and a particular plus.
How do we define
foldr?
Because
we defined this pattern here, so now we
have to define this thing
itself as a higher-order function.
So we have to have a function
that takes f and v as parameters and then
captures the recursion.
Here is the definition of foldr as a
higher-order function.
It takes first an operation that
replaces
cons, so that is a function of type
a -> b -> b.
The second parameter is v. That is the
value that we are replacing
the empty list with.
And then we get a function from list
of a to b.
The definition here is straightforward.
Foldr of f and v and the empty list,
that was v
and foldr of f and v and x:xs
is the recursive invocation of foldr
of f and v
and then we call f on x. So instead of
the funny plus
we use f.
But even though you can look at
this definition, this
recursive definition, the easiest way
to think about foldr
as I said, is a function that replaces
everywhere
the empty list by v and
it replaces the cons
operator by f.
Everywhere where you see empty list
it becomes v, everywhere where you
see cons
it becomes f. And then it
just goes recursively like that.
For example: we evaluate sum
of 1,2,3. Sum is defined as foldr of
plus and 0
of 1,2,3. Now we expand the definition
of lists. We know that
1,2,3 means 1 cons 2 cons 3
cons empty list. And now you see again
why the syntactic sugar for lists is so
useful, because this would be very
tedious to write. We don't want to write
this all the time.
I'm super happy that Haskell has a
shorthand for lists
that expands into this. In this case we
have to think about it
a little bit. And now what happens is that
we are going to replace every occurrence
of cons
by plus and every occurrence, which is
one occurrence, of the empty list
by 0. Let's do that.
So it becomes 1 + 2 + 3 + 0.
You see: the structure of the list is
maintained. Foldr is a homomorphism
over lists.
The structure is still the same. It just
replaces the constructors
by another function. If you are familiar
with the visitor pattern, foldr is really
very similar to the visitor pattern.
It visits the list and for every
constructor
it applies a function, and that function
is passed as the parameters to foldr.
If we evaluate 1 + 2 + 3 + 0
the result is 6.
It is obvious what happens with
product 1,2,3.
We go through the same derivation.
Product was defined as
times, 1,
1,2,3. We expand the list. We replace
every occurrence of cons by times and
every occurrence of the empty list by 1.
We evaluate this expression
and the result is 6 again.
Good. Now let's look at some other
examples of foldr. For example the
length of the list. We can define the
length of the list
a function that takes a list of a, for
all types a, and returns an Int.
The length of the empty list is 0 and
the length of the list
x:xs is 1 plus the length of xs.
Haskell programmers are lazy and
since we are not using x
in the right hand side here, we just
use an underscore for x. So we don't have
to think about the name.
We remember the underscore.
When we used that, it really just means
this is a variable but we are not going
to use that in the right hand side.
It is obvious here that length
is another instance of foldr. We are
replacing the empty list with 0
and we are replacing cons with
the function that throws away x
and then adds 1 to the recursive
invocation
of foldr on the list.
Let's make this explicit. So we
do length of 1,2,3. That's the same
as length
of 1 cons 2 cons 3 cons empty list.
That's the same as 1 + 1 +
1 + 0, which is 3.
So if we replace cons with a function
lambda underscore n -> 1 + n
and the empty list by 0, we get exactly
what we want. So cons is replaced
in this step here by the function
that throws away the first argument, so
we don't write it
and then it takes a second argument
and adds 1 to it.
You see exactly that is what happens in
that step.
What we have found is that length can
be defined
as foldr of lambda underscore n
1 + n and 0. Let's look at another
example:
reverse. Reverse of the empty list
is the empty list and reverse of x:xs
is reverse of xs append
with the singleton list of x.
By now we should be trained to see this
pattern.
We see two cases: the empty list
and the list x:xs and on the
right hand side
we see that function reverse applied to
the rest of the list
plus some function involving x
that we apply to the result of
this recursive invocation. And in
this case
the reverse is a little bit tricky,
because the
recursive call appears here on the left
instead of with length where it appeared,
the recursive call
let's go back to length here, where the
recursive call
appeared on the right.
But this won't fool us. That's just
simple.
No worries. Let's look at reverse.
Reverse 1,2,3.
Again that's the same as reverse 1 cons 2
cons 3 cons empty list
which is the same as empty list
concatenated to 3, concatenated to 2
concatenated to 1, which is 3,2,1.
What function are we
using to replace cons and what function
are we using to replace the empty list?
You see here that things are reversed, but
that shouldn't fool us, because we see here
that the parentheses are right. So we
are doing something with 1
and the recursive call. The fact that
this is reversed
that is not important. So if we replace
cons with the function
x xs goes to xs
cons x, so there you see that it's swapped
the x appears to the left here and
to the right here
and we replace empty list with the
empty list, then this all works out.
So we can define
reverse as foldr of
this function, where we replace cons by
the function
cons, takes a value and something else,
and we put
x to the right, because we are reversing
the list.
And the empty list is already reversed.
Now if we write this
in pointfree style, we can write this
a little bit shorter and write it as:
appending ys
to the end is the same as folding
cons with ys.
If I want to append a list, I'm just
replacing the empty list by that list
and I'm leaving all the
cons alone.
So why is foldr useful?
Many recursive functions on lists such
like sum
product, and, or, are
quite simple to define using foldr. We
have seen length, which was a little bit
harder
and reverse, which was even a little bit
but still very simple. In the exercises
you will have to define map and filter
in terms of foldr.
We leave that to the exercises, but
since you have seen these examples
that should be easy.
But the nice thing is that we can define
properties of foldr
such as fusion and the banana split rule
that's why I was eating a banana
earlier on, and we can use these
properties to calculate more efficient
programs. In particular fusion means
that I have two functions. One that uses
foldr to
traverse one list and return another
list. And if I do another foldr
on the result of that, I can fuse
these two together, such that the
intermediate list is never
constructed. So programs can be
optimized
if you write them in this higher-order
pattern. Don't forget to do the
exercises.
Part of them will be to define
map and filter in terms of foldr
but by now that should be easy and you
can do that
while you are enjoying a nice banana.
Thank you
and see you next time.